continuing with the social justice
activism panels at south by southwest
not gay jared and i attended the my body
is not
safe for work fat pride breakout session
to ask a few simple
medically accurate if mildly triggering
questions
but before that it's important that you
see the narrative
they were using to set the stage
concerned trolling i think is a big
thing in general in this space and it's
like are you actually concerned do you
actually compare
care at all about my well-being um if
you did maybe you wouldn't be harassing
me because it's not great for my mental
health
it's the gateway to basically just
saying i don't like you i don't like
what i'm seeing
um we know that we aren't supposed to be
mean to people we
that's another very popular idea and a
good one that we're not supposed to
bully we're not supposed to call people
names and wag fingers
so we express worry over them instead
but it all amounts to the same it almost
the same as don't don't show me what
you're showing me
but for me it really is about just
reclaiming it and saying like i'm fat
and the fact that you still find me
attractive is your problem if you see a
fat girl online who hates herself and is
in sweatpants and talking about how
miserable she is and crying people are
much more likely to be supportive
of her diet and her exercise
but when you're confident and you're
saying i love myself and here i am in a
bikini and i'm okay as i am
immediately people have you know really
strong feelings about that
pause so wait you mean to say that when
you're vulnerable and upset
people are kind and consoling and
willing to offer supportive advice
but when you're arrogant and bombastic
people are put off they've got some
nerve on them
i am also i don't know
voluptuous sure i have really big boobs
i guess
but um i am fat and that's okay
you touched on something which i think
was important earlier about health care
affordable access to health care being
you know uh i think you said a human
right so in that sense
with the fact that people who are
overweight like myself or obese
are three to seven times more likely to
develop diabetes
or cost 256 billion dollars more per
year
isn't that a concern of the taxpayer
don't they have a right to have an
opinion
and just like smoking encourage
healthier body styles if the taxpayer is
involved in this decision
i think i mean this is like obviously an
incredibly nuanced conversation i think
it starts a lot younger and a lot
earlier
than by the time anyone has developed
some of those issues or gain the weight
i think you can't talk about that
without also talking about the food
industry and
corn subsidies and access to health care
for prenatal care
and early childhood intervention and
education you can't just talk about
that people have diabetes and have more
likelihood to
end up with diseases that cost the
taxpayer without talking about
the entire approach to body's health
our access to food water uh flood
michigan still doesn't have clean water
hasn't for three years
oh so flint michigan's tap water made
you fat
well that explains it if we see a
statistical risk pool
do we also agree that like insurance
companies should
have the right to discriminate in that
sense i do not i mean
none of us would agree that it's okay to
discriminate against fat bodies up here
but
if you are you know excluding people or
penalizing people based on size you're
not just discriminating based on says
you're also discriminating based on
you know a number of things including
racial and ethnic backgrounds for
example
what pause did she just insinuate that
black people are fat
none of us have an issue with promoting
healthy lifestyles i think in kate in
our case it actually is a really big
part of
of our identities and brand like nichola
and i talk a lot about
we're both gluten-free et cetera because
of our conditions
oh it's the gluten
that's the ticket and that being said i
am very much
someone who wants to promote living in
healthy and healthy ways but i don't
equate that necessarily to
a certain size 700 chance more
likelihood
of someone you know developing heart
disease or diabetes of course
should we promote that you know for kids
who are coming up we agreed that
to lose weight no we should not promote
to lose weight we should promote healthy
behaviors
there's a much larger issue of the way
we
stigmatize bodies the way they're
approached in the medical
and health industry the way that the
medical industrial complex is structured
in general
course not it must have been the gluten
and what have you of course that
statement begs the question as to just
how the medical industrial complex uh
managed to
so effectively target exclusively these
women but there wasn't enough time to
get into that so
not gay jared had a question of his own
appreciate put this on him
great um question for you uh i just you
talked about some studies and
i'm sure there's probably a lot of
studies out there but there's been
several studies that show that
when polling men uh versus this one out
of new south wales and sydney
the study involved in sixty thousand
sixty thousand volunteers rating almost
one thousand variations of the female
figure
and what the discovery was was that um
more attractive ones are almost always
tall uh
and thinner rather than large and curvy
um question for you is is it possible
that within uh
fighting the idea of body shaming
there's a
there's actually a possibility of
shaming
natural male biology that prefers uh
that are a leaner um healthier women
what about i think it's what about that
survey that is natural male biology
they're not
societal i think a lot of times
socialized um i think a lot of our
preferences are socialized are they
asking babies but that is
something that's really apparent when
you go to other cultures and ask their
preferences
like our attraction is so much
specialized
of course it is um okay but i found that
this is actually true across
generationally the idea that people just
or men just biologically
are starting to come out of the womb
attracted to thin tall women is like
ridiculous
and also
[Applause]
[Music]
you're allowed to be attracted to
whoever you're attracted to there's
nothing wrong with that
if a person is not attracted to me
because my body is larger i don't care
there's a million of other people who
are um in fact i wish
you were mentally stated
with the maximum triggering occurring we
had to get the hell out of there but as
cis white males
we wanted to ensure that we weren't
wrong with our information so we decided
to sit down with a local doctor
dr mike simpson to get his professional
opinion also
side note we did have one other
cameraman with
us at that panel but he got eaten
[Music]
so now you're telling me what i am
obligated to do by the oath that i took
and what the government
actually has on a checklist that i must
discuss with you the moment you
get on the scale of my emergency room
and you're over a certain basic
metabolic index
that triggers a question on the
electronic medical record did you
discuss weight control with this patient
just like if you say i'm a smoker
did you discuss smoking cessation so now
you're telling me that i am trolling you
because i'm doing what i'm remembering
yeah oh and by the way
by the way because of uh the affordable
care act and many other governmental
restrictions
if i don't ask you that question i don't
get to bill for full price for that
chart now i don't care i'm not in this
for the money i am in it because i care
about people's health but don't accuse
me of trolling
when i'm telling you you are going to
die you're going to this guy really
needs to check his md
privilege again why does this matter
because just like the anti-free speech
panel we covered earlier this week this
entire
fat pride movement is centered around
controlling what people are allowed and
are not allowed to say when you
categorize everything
as hate speech including medically
correct assessments designed to keep you
alive
you eliminate the ability for any
conversation to take place
as you see here even with issues that
are
literally life and death but
don't tell anyone that's just concern
trolling hey if you like this clip
you're like most of the internet you
have a short attention spin but it was
taken from the full show you can see it
in the box playing next to me
uh that's once a week on thursday's full
one and a half hour show or
you can join the mug club uh for the
daily show we have to take some of that
off youtube because they're monitoring
us
and censoring our words